I know what's happening here my mom
called up BuzzFeed and told everyone to
say nice things to me right
so here's how it's gonna work I'm gonna
go and give the first compliment and
then that person is gonna go and give
somebody else a compliment it's gonna be
a compliment chain I actually want to
tell you that I think you're great you
have such positive beautiful energy no
and I love your work in what you do and
how you make people feel special in the
office so much so here's the thing
you're gonna have to go and compliment
somebody else so who do you want to
compliment
I want to compliment Steph you just
started working here and you've been
like guns blazing and working hard and
motivated and like with like a really
positive attitude and like a non-stop
smile I just wanted to let you know how
great you are and I hope your greatness
rubs off on me you are such a kind and
caring person and when we were both
interns you sat across from me and
answered any questions that I had and
you were really helpful and I'm very
glad that we're friends I think you work
really hard and I think you put
everything you have into all the work
you do and I just like really wanted to
applaud you for that
I appreciate you and I'm glad you're
here I wanted to thank you for being
such an amazing person and you always
help me when I need help with a bunch of
[ __ ] and I just wanted to say you're
very sweet man and you're very beautiful
and very nice hey Shane hey you're
beautiful and thank you I just wanna
thank you for being you
just give me a hug yeah whoa I thought
of someone I wanted to compliment
I won't compliment you thank you always
thankful for your positivity you're one
of my favorite people around this office
I just wanted to tell you that thank you
I feel the same way about you I wanted
to say that thank you so much for being
my friend and you inspire me every day
but now I feel really happy and warm
here the best kiss
Thanks